hey wait a minute you knew that many  actions in our daily life increase the  effort of climate change right  it's time for everyone to invest in our  planet earth  we're putting policies in place to  become the first climate neutral  continent by 2050.  transport emissions represent the 25  percent of the eu greenhouse gas  emissions  for that we are pushing for a greener  urban mobility and from an eu  sustainable rain network  more than 80 percent of marine ladder is  plastics for that we introduce industry  waste standards and a ban on selected  single-use plastic products  and this one are just some of the  actions that we take to prevent climate  change  now tell us in the comments what actions  you're taking to minimize your carbon  footprint